well new this morning over the past
weeks las vegas metro police department
has discovered credit card skimmers
across the valley yeah sure they're
trying to raise awareness about this
because they think there may be
thousands of victims our bianco holmen's
got more information bianca is it
possible to see what a skimmer looks
like before you get caught
yeah well nate and sherry it looks just
like the normal terminal at first glance
but the key is just to take your time
and maybe touch the terminal because a
lot of these things are put on by
two-sided tape so they can fall off
easily so we checked in with lvmpd their
financial investigative team and they
say that it takes seconds to put these
fake point-of-sale terminals in matter
of fact you could be standing behind
someone while they install one before
you go to check out lvmpd says it's best
to use the tap to pay or use a credit
card or cash most credit cards have
fraud policies so that none of your
money is actually taken and you can
receive your money back faster unless
you use a debit card where it's gone
it's always good to report it because it
can be part of another crime and most
people that use these devices are parts
of groups of people they're not just an
individual doing it you've got a group
of people 20 30 people
just doing this making a living off of
it
now if you feel like you've been scammed
then contact your bank or financial
institution immediately then call police
hearing from as many victims as possible
helps them catch the scammers and gomez
tells us they have caught many suspects
any tampering with these terminals or
being in possession of them is a felony
and if convicted you could face years of
jail time and gomez also says that this
issue is not just in one particular part
of the valley it's happening across the
valley so keep an eye out bianca holman
live local now